>> FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TAKING THE
QUESTION FROM REPORTERS.
BUT FROM THE LIST OF
PREDETERMINED REPORTERS TOOK NO
LEAP-- NOTABLY ONLY THREE THIS T
THEY ASKED ABOUT MULTIPLE
CRISES, INCLUDING THE CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
SOUTH -- THOUSANDS OF MOSTLY
PATIENT MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
CAMPED OUT AT A DEL RIO BRIDGE
IN TEXAS.
THE IMAGES HAPPENED SHOCKING TO
SAY THE LEAST BIT BUT FOUR OF
BORDER PATROL AGENTS CHASING
MIGRANTS ON HORSEBACK HAVE THE
SPORT THE MOST OUTBREAK --
OUTCRY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS REMAINED
SILENT ABOUT THE SITUATION UNTIL
TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT THREW BORDER
PATROL UNDER THE BUS.
OF.
>> Reporter: DO YOU TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE CHAOS
THAT IS UNFOLDING?
>> President Biden: OF COURSE
I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS HORRIBLE TO SEE PEOPLE
TREATED LIKE -- BEING STRAPPED.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY.
THEY WILL BE -- THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES.
IT IS AN EMBARRASSMENT BEYOND AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
IT IS DANGEROUS.
IT IS WRONG.
IT SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO DODGED
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION FROM PETER
DOOCY.
[INDISTINCT]
>> ALWAYS DODGING THOSE
QUESTIONS.
FILM ILLUSION HAS REPORTED JUST
BEFORE HE CAME TO THE AREAS THAT
THAT’S PHOTOGRAPHER WHO TOOK
THAT PICTURE, THE INFAMOUS
PICTURE OF THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS IN DEAUVILLE SAYS HE AND
HIS COLLEAGUES NEVER SAW AGENTS
WHIPPING ANYONE IN THE PHOTOS
ARE BEING MISCONSTRUED.
NOT ONLY BY PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO
IS LYING ABOUT THIS, MOMENTS
AGO, HIS OWN VICE PRESIDENT
COUPLE DOWN ON THE LIVE.
-- DOUBLED DOWN ON THE LIE.
>> Vice President Harris: I
HAVE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT THE IMAGES
THAT USE ALL OF THOSE
LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ON
HORSES.
I WAS OUTRAGED BY IT.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
AND DEEPLY TROUBLING.
OF THERE’S BEEN NO AN
INVESTIGATION THAT IS BEING
CONDUCTED, WHICH I FULLY
SUPPORT.
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE
CONSEQUENCES AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
HUMAN BEINGS SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED THAT WAY, AND AS WE ALL
KNOW, IT ALSO EVOKE IMAGES OF
SOME OF THE WORST MOMENTS OF
THEIR HISTORY.
WHERE THAT KIND OF BEHAVIOR HAS
BEEN USED AGAINST THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY HAS BEEN
USED AGAINST AFRICAN-AMERICANS
DURING TIMES OF HIS -- SLAVERY.
>> LOOK.
JUST TO GO BACK TO THE PRESENT
FOR A SECOND.
THE EVIDENCE -- NOT SHOW THE
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE -- THE
PHOTOGRAPHER HAS COME FORWARD.
IT IS NOT SHILDT WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS SAY HAPPEN.
PUTTING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
BORDER PATROL ON HORSES.
YOU HAVE HEARD THAT FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE AND I DON’T
KNOW IF YOU COPY FROM LESLIE
MARSHALL.
JUST PREVIOUSLY, A DEMOCRAT ON
MY SHOW, SHE WENT INTO QUICK
DETAIL ABOUT THIS.
ABOUT HOW THAT IS HOW THEY
HANDLED, AND MIND ENFORCEMENT
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY HANDLE
THINGS.
THE PRESIDENT DOES THAT JUDGE,
JURY, AND HE IS NOT WILLING TO
BELIEVE ANY OTHER SCENARIO OTHER
THAN THE FANTASY OR NARRATIVE
THAT HE HAS BEEN HIS HEAD SO
FAR.
EVIDENCE COMES FORTH THAT
SOMETHING UNTOWARD HAPPENED, I’M
SURE SOMEONE WILL RUSH TO GET.
BUT NOW, THE ONLY THING THEY ARE
RUSHING TO HIS JUDGMENT.
THAT IS HUMBLE BECAUSE THE VERY
SAME PEOPLE YOU HAVE CALLED ON
TO KEEP US SAFE WHEN POLICIES
WERE DRIVING OUR SAFETY INTO THE
GROUND AT THAT BORDER COAT THEY
ARE DOING THEIR JOB MIGHT
ANTEDATE RIGHT NOW.
AND A HEALTHY THINK IT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL.
AND BY THE WAY, WHY DIDN’T
SECRETARY OF THE DHS SAY
ANYTHING WHEN HE SAW THOSE SAME
MEN AND WOMEN ON HORSEBACK THIS
WEEK WHEN HE WENT TO THE BORDER?
ON ALL SHADES OF CONFUSED HOW
KAMALA HARRIS AT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WANT TO
POINT TYPICALLY SITUATION WHERE
THE FACTS DON’T -- NOW, IS IT A
TERRIBLE IMAGE?
CLEARLY PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT
IT.
SO WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
CONSEQUENCES, I AM SURE IT
STARTS WITH HIMSELF.
IF YOU WANT MORE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, YOU WILL NEED MORE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND.
YOU NEED MORE PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER.
LET’S SEE IF THE PRESIDENT CAN
RECTIFY HAS BEEN BROKEN UNDER
HIS ADMINISTRATION FOR THE LAST
EIGHT AND A HALF MONTHS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND FOX’S REPORTERS INC. THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN USING HORSES
FOR 117 YEARS.
HIS REPORTING SHOWS THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN SCAPEGOATED.
THEY CAN’T DEFEND THEMSELVES.
INSTEAD THEY ARE BEING THROWN
UNDER THE BUS AND THEY SAY
TWIRLING IS THE TECHNIQUE USED
OFTEN.
IT IS TO KEEP SOMEONE ELSE IN A
-- AN ILLEGAL MIGRANT FROM
GRABBING A HORNETS.
BUT HEY, DON’T LISTEN TO THE
FACTS.
LISTEN TO MAXINE WATERS AND HER
VISION.
>> WHAT DO HELL -- ONE OF THE
HELL ARE WE DOING HERE?
THIS TAKES US BACK HUNDREDS OF
YEARS.
THIS IS WORSE THAN WHAT WE
WITNESSED IN CALABRIA.
>> EMILY?
>> I CAN’T SPEAK TO MESSY WATER
PUMP -- MAXINE WATERS’ EMOTIONAL
REACTION.
SO WHAT YOU ALLUDED TO, ERICA
MOUNTED GUARD PATROLLED THE
BORDER ON HORSEBACK BEGINNING IN
1904.
IN FACT, THIS -- THESE HORSES
WERE MORE IMPORTANT TO UNITED
STATES THAN UNIFORMS BECAUSE WE
ENSURED THAT OUR GUARD AT THAT
TIME HAD HORSES OVER UNIFORMS
WHICH CAME OVER 30 YEARS
LATER.
SO THE CONCEPTS THAT THIS IS
SOMEHOW NEW BECAUSE IT IS A
VALUE FOR THE REASON THAT HORSES
ARE USED IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TRAVERSE UP TO 50 MILES
A DAY IS THAT THEY CAN TRAVERSE
TERRAIN THAT IS -- THAT
VEHICLES.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY, JUST USE ATVS,
ESPECIALLY THERE IN TEXAS, WHICH
THE PRESIDENT WOULD KNOW IF HE
EVENTUALLY WENT DOWN TO THE
DUCKS BORDER CAPTIVES, A VARIETY
OF CANE THAT GROWS THERE THAT
MAKES IT IN ACCESSIBLE TO
ANYTHING BUT HORSEBACK.
SO --
>> AS EASY TO KIND IN.
>> EXACTLY.
AND IN TERMS OF -- KEEP IN MIND,
GUYS DID THAT INSULTING OR
HURTING AN ANIMAL ASSOCIATED
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IS A
FAMILY.
SO, WHY WOULD WE HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED AS A FELONY AND YET
NOT ENABLED BORDER PATROL OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO USE TECHNIQUES TO
HAVE PEOPLE STAND BACK FROM THE
ANIMAL THAT IS AN EXTENSION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IN THAT
MILITARY WE ALSO, DOES NICK AS
OFFICERS.
FOR THESE GUYS TO INVOKE
LABORING IN THESE HORRIBLE --
SLAVERY IN THESE HORRIBLE,
ATROCIOUS IMAGES INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT THE FACTS.
AND BORDER PATROL IS USING NO
HORSES WHATSOEVER.
>> EPS, TEXAS DPS IS NOW
PATROLLING THE BORDER.
THE STATE PATROL IS NOW
RESPONSIBLE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO NEED MORE
PEOPLE.
WHEN THINGS ACTUALLY DO EQUAL
THE HORRORS OF SLAVERY, WE
SHOULD CALL THEM ALPINE AND 20
DON’T CONNECTING WATERS AND
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS DOING THAT,
IS NOT THAT THEY WERE NOT BAD
IMAGES AND FOR THE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE AND GETS, HORRIFYING
THAT YOU CAN TALK WITH THEM
ABOUT IT.
BUT IT IS NOT LIKE SLEEPY.
AND WE CANNOT SAY THAT THINGS
AREN’T LIKE THINGS WENT THEY ARE
NOT BECAUSE WAS, EVERYTHING IS
SLAVERY PROTECTED HAS NO MEANING
THE EXPECTED IT IS SOMETHING
WORSE -- IF SOMETHING RESIDENT
SLAVERY PEPIN, HAPPENED UNDER
BIDEN’S WATCH.
BUT LOOK TO REGARDLESS OF WHAT
MELISSA SAID AND BIDEN SAYS THAT
WE KNOW THAT IS NOT TRUE.
LOOKING TO THE FACTS.
BUT BANNING HORSES, BREAD.
THAT IS WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
THERE WAS A SIMPLE QUESTION.
YOU CAN GIVE ME THE ANSWER.
WHAT IS THE BEST WAY TO STOP
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION?
BUILD A WALL AND BANNED HORSES.
>> BECAUSE ISN’T -- IT IS NOT
ABOUT STOPPING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THIS IS THE DISTRACTION THAT
THEY COULDN’T FIND.
THE QUESTION TO JOE BIDEN WAS
NOT ABOUT HORSES AND WHIPPING
WHICH HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
DEBUNKED.
IT IS FAKE NEWS.
THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE
DISASTER AT THE BORDER AND
BECAUSE OF THESE IMAGES, WHICH
OF THE PHOTOGRAPHER EVEN SAYS IT
DON’T REPRESENT REALITY, JOE
BIDEN, COM LIKE HARRIS, AND
MAXINE WATERS THIS TRACK AWAIT
DON’T LOOK AT BIDEN GO.
DON’T LOOK UNDER THE BRIDGE IN
DEL RIO, TEXAS.
DON’T LOOK AT THE DISASTER WE
CREATED.
LOOK AT THIS ONE GUY ON A HORSE
USING HIS REINS AROUND.
IT HAS BEEN TOTALLY
MISCONSTRUED.
AND I’M SO GLAD YOU SAID WHAT
YOU SAID.
A QUICK MAXINE WATERS CUP TO SAY
WORSE THAN SLAVERY, WHAT AN
INSULT TO ANY -- WHO IS ACTUALLY
EQUIPPED BY A SLEEP MASTER.
THAT IS -- IT IS SUCH EGREGIOUS
RHETORIC.
I DON’T KNOW HOW TO RESPOND TO
IT.
THEY ARE USING THE HORSE THINK
OF THE.
THEY WANT MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> THEY DO WITH.
AND A LOT OF QUESTIONS WHEN THEY
TAKE TO THE PODIUM AT 2:30.
HE SAID HE SAW NOTHING
INAPPROPRIATE.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, FACTS